Harry your speed it's getting worse
barely hanging on I can't catch my
breath all I can think about is if I'll
be fast enough to save another life
flash is losing his speed drain him of
the rest now it's just taking control of
his pain you can't feed off of him
anymore you know
[Music]
it's over it so it no
the satellite scans say there are no
traces of thawne's negative tachyons to
be found in any organic matter on the
planet has four Nash says he'll confirm
that she didn't feel any of thawne's
energy inside him well according to
three-dimensional imaging Nash's brain
waves are bone free I guess this means
STAR Labs has successfully completed its
very first exorcism Don's gone for no
right sons tachyons might have
dissipated but they weren't destroying
it which means he's not that just
formless it's probably out there looking
for another body right now like a
red-eyed pissed-off oldham or it comes
back we'll be ready we go check on Nash
are you all you guys make up yet mm-hmm
thank God
guys are we sure creating an artificial
Speed Force is the way to go
I mean anyone who came in contact with
on speed force got hurt ours will be
different yeah but we still don't even
know where to start
actually I do every time Thawne tried to
hurt me using Knorr memory really what
he did was reminded me how much I loved
her
let me realized that she's the answer
Norris Journal Don taught nor how to
build a speed horse now she can teach us
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new flash season 6
episode 16 video and an explainer for
what's going on with that Grant Gustin
black flash picture of himself that he
just posted that made everybody freak
out there's a bunch of Easter eggs I'll
explain what's really going on with this
as cool as it looks it also explained
what's going on with the rest of the
flash episodes this season so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing an
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite black flash moment on the video
been a while since we've seen the black
flash you only see him during really big
episodes with Easter eggs or if they're
doing big flashbacks to zoom like when
they brought him back for season 5
episode 8 because it was the hundredth
episode spectacular I know everyone's
asking me to make a video about the
whole Ezra Miller situation with the
footage of him choking a fan and what's
gonna happen to him is he still gonna be
in the flash movie I'm not really
planning on making a video about that
until Warner Brothers says something
about the incident and I'm not expecting
them to make any kind of announcements
till way later this year so we'll talk
about the black flash stuff first then
I'll talk about what's happening with
the rest of the episodes this season and
how they're gonna fix everything because
of the virus delays then I'll talk about
the rest of the story and where they
leave off here with reverse flashes
essence his negative speed force looking
for another body to inhabit like Red
Death Easter eggs and everything that's
going on with a brand new version of the
Speed Force that they're trying to
create so this morning out of nowhere
Grant Gustin post this picture of
himself in the black flash costume
everybody freaked out wait a minute
what's going on here are they getting
ready for a Barry black flash storyline
everyone thought that they killed the
black flash back during season 3 when
they killed the zoom version of black
flash this is a very prominent Barry
Allen black flash story at the beginning
of Geoff Johns old original flash
rebirth storyline from 2009 if you
haven't been reading the current flash
comics they also just brought black
flash back as part of the force quest
storyline that's the storyline where
Barry Allen and Wally West are trying to
save their friends in the Speed Force
which is dying
so obviously that sounds familiar what's
happening on the TV show the Speed Force
on the TV show is slowly dying but based
on what Grant Gustin said about this
picture it doesn't sound like they're
planning on any big black flash Barry
storyline on the TV show and this is
just one of many
costume test that they've done but that
it looks so cool that he actually
himself wants to do a black flash
storyline like berry becoming the black
flash so maybe at some point during
season seven even though there's been
all these big virus delays they still
are doing flash season seven I don't
know how many more seasons they're gonna
do the TV show but if they're any big
crazy twists that they've been sitting
on this whole time season seven would be
the time to do that but talking about
the rest of the episodes we obviously
know we're gonna get episode 16 because
they drop the trailers for it but what
the CW has announced is that they're
actually going to air the flash finale
whatever that winds up being whichever
episode on May 19th and it's not coming
back for episode 16 until April 21st I
don't know how they're gonna try and
resolve whatever their storyline is they
still have the mirror master plot we
still have reverse-flash trying to
inhabit someone's body there's a lot of
big questions about how they're going to
resolve their storyline we know that
godspeed is coming in episode 18 and it
sounds like they're setting up some big
god speed stuff for season seven aside
from the mirror master stuff which seems
like it's pretty straightforward they
have to answer what they're gonna do
with this new Speed Force they're gonna
try and create which will obviously
influence what's happening during the
season 7 storyline so much of the
storyline around this artificial speed
force they're trying to create revolves
around Nora's journal that's impervious
to timeline changes which is why it
still exists
my assumption if they had had all the
episodes that they wanted this season
and there were no delays they would have
found a way to bring it back around and
show you some sort of cameo scene
setting up Nora or a new version of Nora
returning to the show with maybe her
twin brother from the comics remember
dawn and Dawn that was what that scene
with reverse-flash during season 5
episode 8 was about when he met Nora for
the first time dawn I'm assuming she's
like no my name is Nora any kind of
chuckles to himself like ah
they've already messed with the timeline
Barry's already changed things and his
children are different he doesn't have
twins anymore they still haven't paid
off that line from season 4 the
gibberish where he says we're going to
need more diapers they've never said
that and they've said pretty much every
other line of dialogue of gibberish that
he came out of the speedforce saying at
the beginning of that season I don't
mind them reducing the episode count
that's not that big of a deal it just
means less filler episodes but hopefully
they get all the footage that they need
so that everything makes sense by the
end of whatever this season is going to
be whether that's episode 19 or episode
20 or however they worked the final
couple of episodes they were able to
film before they were forced to go on
break
I'm really glad they didn't frig the
reverse-flash in the last episode he's
still alive out there somewhere his
essence is negative Speed Force energy
looking for another body the really cool
thing about that storyline in the way
they ended this last episode is it
teases a whole bunch of other big
concepts that they can use in future
seasons including the very last episode
of the flash so just going down the list
of Easter eggs and really cool story
lines starting obviously with that
ending so early prediction early theory
here if you're not a longtime flash
comic book reader there was a really
cool storyline that explained what
happened to Barry Allen after he died
during comic book crisis on Infinite
Earths so in the comics he dies just
goes away wally west becomes the main
version of the flash and everybody just
kind of wonders where he went during the
wally west era in the 90s before geoff
johns came along and did flash rebirth
there was a really cool storyline that
actually said that instead of actually
just straight-up dying during crisis
barry allen became the bolt of lightning
that originally gave him powers so what
I'm hoping is is they use this reverse
flash twist where reverse flash turns
into pure speed force energy then goes
and inhabits someone else's body for
Barry in the flash finale where he
finally sacrifices himself in a big
crisis comic book style twist but
instead of just dying and never coming
back
he actually goes back to the pilot
episode in this very first moment and he
becomes the bolt of lightning that
originally gave him powers it would just
be a nice way to bookend the series so
that it ties right back to that original
moment the other cool Easter Egg here
for reverse-flash trying to inhabit
other people's bodies with his Speed
Force energy is the Red Death character
because Red Death is a fusion speedster
if you're a big Dragon Ball Z Dragon
Ball super fan it's kind of like the
Gogeta version of the flash with two of
them fused together they did that for
the Grodd episode which I feel was also
another Red Death teaser
but everyone let me know in the comments
if they have to cancel the last couple
of episodes how do you think they're
gonna try and end the finale if they
haven't shot a lot of the footage that
they wanted to for the original finale
whatever winds up happening I'll do a
video for it if there's any big hanging
questions or plot threads don't worry
I'll try to include that in my flash
videos episode 16 is gonna be on April
21st they'll probably drop another
trailer to remind everyone next week
because it's been so long since we've
had an episode so post all your big
questions and theories in the comments
below
everyone click here to learn about
cosmic Thor and beta ray bill in Thor
for love and thunder and click here for
my brand new spider-man into the spider
verse 2 teaser trailer breakdown thank
you so much for watching everyone stays
safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]